foreign
as a physical therapist even though I
got a PhD in
neurobiology because I wanted to solve
the motor control problems of the stroke
patient
I stayed very Physically Active I
started really running and doing things
when I started my PhD studies and after
encountering this physician and and
learned a bit about nutrition
breaking all the family Tendencies
and then again learning about
musculoskeletal problems even though I
was really interested in working with
neurological patients people with spinal
cord injury head injury stroke
I had always had this tendency to look
at how people moved and I totally tried
to figure out why they were moving the
way they were moving Etc
and got involved with musculoskeletal
patients and they started getting better
so I had to figure that out
and then I applied my own ideas to to
myself in fact there I don't know how
folks who you want to get at but they're
really some funny stories connected with
that oh let's do it oh yeah no we love
funny stories around here and it really
related to doing this quadruped little
exercise because
so one one sort of funny story was
I was really poor going through getting
my PhD because I didn't have any income
and was living off of a minimum amount
of money
and so I I didn't
get to buy new clothes very often
and I had a pair of slacks that I was
wearing for a long time and a friend
actually took me out to play golf and it
was an older woman at that time and
we're out playing golf and she says you
know surely you've got your pants on
backwards and I said you know I'm
working on my PhD I think ought to be
able to know how to put my pants on
and so we started looking at the darts
and sure enough I had them on backwards
well before
before my alignment was such that they
looked all right but now that I was
doing this quadruped exercise
they didn't look all right they were
looking funny because I had changed the
Curves in my back and my buttocks and so
that's why she caught the idea that I
wasn't wearing my pants right
which quadruped movements were these
it's just the idea of being in quadruped
and just letting your back go down and
then rocking back
mm-hmm
I tended to sit ride the bicycle I was a
a catcher for three different softball
teams so I was really in a posterior
tilt with a really flat back got it and
I had never really
gone the other way
and just for people who are listening if
you don't know just do it to imagine if
you imagine that the sort of the the
pelvis as a bowl of soup posterior tilt
you're kind of pouring soup out the back
of your Elvis just holding it in the
middle yeah yeah right yeah got it okay
so your back your whole back goes kind
of flat then and when you're pushing
your hips back you're facilitating more
of a natural curve in the lower back I
was you know getting my hips to bend and
yeah letting my back go down so it's
getting more of a curve and I think also
decreasing a bit of a Tennessee towards
the thoracic hyphosis
the other thing that was really an
interesting I I used to bowl you know
like with a bowling ball and while I was
in my PhD program which took me six
years
I didn't have any money to bowl and so
when I went and got my bowling ball out
again I had to change the finger grips
because I had stretched my finger
flexors out and so the finger grips no
longer fit me because my fingers were
were longer can you explain that see
your your grips had been molded to
fingers that were well my fingers were
always flexed from everything I did
right and I never really thought about
stretching them out and so when you're
in quadruped
you end up stretching those all out
right okay I see right instead of so for
people who are listening because we're
making movements with their hands and
gestures with their hands oh you can't
see we're gonna make the video available
as well but some people will only hear
audio so instead of being sort of that
keyboard
it's you know Hawk Talon position when
you're in quadruped right as if you were
doing a push-up but not that push-up
position if your hands are flat on the
floor then you're going to be stretching
those flexors stretching across the
wrist and across the fingers yeah got it
so you had to change your bowling ball
that's wild yeah and then the other
thing is I had always worn my shoes off
so that they were going off to the side
and
after I did this you know few years of
this quadruped rocking I didn't walk in
the same way and I didn't have my shoes
weren't worn off to the side from just
walking oh interesting so worn off to
the side you mean the shoes on the
inside were worn or on the yeah yeah
like the outside of the right and the
inside of the left so there were all
these little changes that took place
just from improving my alignment partly
with that so to go on to answer your
full question so what do I do these days
guess what I still do quadruped I don't
go all the way back and sit on my heels
and I also want to tell you about one
thing people need to know about that
exercise
and then
I do a modified
push-ups modified push-ups in prone and
I think that if you could do this
carefully it'd be good is
in prone I I flex my knee so that my leg
as much as possible is falling
falling on my thigh
so is this similar to what you're
describing
you're laying down on your chest yeah
I'm laying down face down bend my knee
and I tried to get my leg
to fall back on my thigh because I don't
want to hold it bent at 90.
in other words if you Flex if you bend
your knee you can go to 90 degrees if
you go more than 90 degrees your leg is
falling on your thigh I see right your
lower leg is sort of falling under your
hamstring yes that's your thigh yeah got
it okay
in that position
then I lift my thigh off of the floor I
do hip extension but not high there's
only 10 degrees of motion but it's a way
to stretch it's a way to use your
gluteal muscle because you can't if you
use your hamstring you'll get a cramp
yeah you'll get a bad cramp in your
hamstring
so just a little bit of hip extension to
use my gluteal muscle how many
repetitions are you doing on each side
or what is I just do 10 repetitions on
one side and then 10 repetitions on the
other and you're doing roughly 10
repetitions of the quadruped rocking as
well yep I'm not sure if that's original
15 push-ups 15 modified push-ups
modified is your Naser vent I don't go
to my toes got it okay
and then still in the prone position
knees flexed to 90 degrees and then I do
hip rotation
you know in both directions letting my
lower leg come in and then go out
come in and go out right so just if I
can translate and please
correct me if I'm getting this wrong but
you're bending one you're laying on your
on your chest one leg bent to 90 degrees
and basically windshield wiper with that
lower leg on each side yeah but I do
both at the same time oh you do both at
the same time okay yeah so they're not
quite you know ones maybe 80 the other
Maybe 70.
just
because it doesn't take all that long
yeah right and then with my knees
extended straight with my lower
extremity straight
I alternate doing hip extension but I
think about using my gluteal muscle
I think about activating my gluteus
maximus
and again only about 10 degrees of hip
extension okay
and then in that same position I do hip
abduction in other words
one leg out to the side ten times
because you use you use your gluteus
medius and that better if you're working
against gravity and extension than you
do when you're supine okay supine you
tend to recruit the tensor too much oh I
see
got it
and
is there anything that that follows that
abductor work
then I go supine I turn over and I think
this is really
you know
I'm pretty good about not having a
kyphosis but
I have to a deduct in supine I add pull
my shoulder blades together and slide my
arms up over my head
so that my arms are all the way up over
my head as much as I can and I'm on a
hard floor
and I'm starting with my hips and knees
bent arms up overhead and then slide one
leg down slide the other leg down and
believe me for an older person who's got
a tendency towards collapso smasho
just getting yourself as stretched out
as possible is so important
um yeah I mean really sounds like for me
with my kyphosis that would also be
important yeah the biggest worry is
going to be with the older person
that if you have a kyphosis you're not
going to be able to get your arms on the
floor all the way up over your head
you don't want any pain on top of your
shoulder because that's not going to be
a good plan so they may need to have a
pillow up there
when they're first starting
to
so their arms don't go all the way back
because you want to avoid any kind of
pain on top of your shoulder but happily
I know how to do it I can do it and then
I do active actively hip and knee Flex
you know bring one knee towards my chest
put it down and the other one
and 10 times with each leg
and then with one foot on the floor I do
a straight leg raise but I don't like
tighten all my leg my thigh muscles so
that my knee is perfectly straight and I
turn it out a little bit so that I don't
use
the tensor
I'm gonna that if I rotate it out you'll
use the psoas more and I think about
tightening my abdominals
okay
because I have had a significant problem
and I I don't want to put too much
stress on my lumbar spine from the
iliopsoas I want to use it but I want to
protect my back that's why I have one
foot on the floor I see that's why
you're doing one leg at a time well yeah
certainly one leg at a time so could you
just reiterate given the last lumbar
issue why you would want to engage the
psoas instead of the tfl in this case
it's a good muscle to use I need to be
able to flex my hip but the tensor
it has a real low threshold for
Activation I mean interestingly enough
if you would scratch the bottom of your
foot the first muscle to go off will be
your tensor fasciae no kidding yeah in
fact I think it's so interesting because
I've tried to contact the World Health
Organization because all over the world
the tensor has run amok but they listen
to me they're not returning the calls no
I know and it's this little bitty wimpy
muscle and you say how can it cause so
much trouble but it sure does you know
it plays a role in what happens to the
knee and plays a role in what happens to
the back and the hip I mean
it's an evil thing but
well anyway you know an interesting
thing one of my colleagues was doing a
study and we actually had a student that
did not have a tensor fasciae
no kidding yeah we didn't throw out a
school or anything but
but anyway I couldn't wait to do all the
tests that we do to look for the length
of the tensor and she was a you know a
fair athlete so it wasn't like it had
been sitting not doing anything if it
was there and I did all the tests and
they were negative which was kind of
supportive to me that indeed the tensor
does do things that aren't so kind to
the rest of the body
so anyway all that to say that's why
when I do the straight leg raise I try
to laterally rotate my hip because I'd
rather use the psoas
and then I would the tfl and it's not
causing me any problems clearly if I
thought I was injuring myself I would
not would not do that and then I do one
other thing with one leg straight and
the other foot on the floor
so that my knee is bent my foot's on the
floor I let my leg go out to the side
and that's my way of trying to work on
controlling rotation with the trunk
mm-hmm my leg goes out to the side it
wants to rotate your pelvis but
Contracting your abdominals prevents
that rotation so that's another way I'm
trying to work my abdominals and then
and then I stand up and you know I'm so
proud of myself because
I can get up from the floor without any
difficulty and
many people at my age are many years
younger than that can't do that
um
and put my back to the wall and then do
what I was telling you to do arms up
overhead and do
do the little side Bend thing
and you do this every day I do and then
I walk three to four miles a day
amazing
sometimes ride a stationary bike
well these are things I'm paying more
and more attention to I'm so impressed
but let me tell you one thing now Tim
that the quadruped as much as I love it
and I think it's important whether you
have a shoulder problem a cervical
problem
Etc is
that one of the things that's a problem
though and can be for several reasons
but again the tensor is one of them if
you rock back and your hip immediately
rotates
in other words I found this in some
patients that
as you rock back your hips should just
flex but if you are monitoring the femur
you can sometimes see that it
immediately rotates
right that is really bad and the reason
why it's really bad is because it's
rotating in your knee joint too and
that's a good way to set yourself up for
an ACL tear anterior cruciate ligament
ooh yeah yeah yeah yeah and I think
people should be monitoring that anybody
that's doing that
one of the things that helps is if you
slightly laterally rotate your hips you
know many people particularly men come
with what we call femoral retroversion
do you know what that is I don't okay
well you probably have it ephemeral
retro version It's a structural
variation and so the femur
as you know has
a head and neck on it it's angled well
it's also rotated on the shaft
right and if it's in the ideal world the
average not the normal the average is
that that rotation is 15 degrees
so the head and neck of the femur are
pointing 15 degrees forward
now many men it's not rotated so what it
means is that when you're doing your hip
rotation you go out a long ways but you
don't go in
that's true for me for sure yeah my
internal rotation is terrible compared
to my external rotation but that's
because you came that way and it should
never change no I mean it and so yeah
and men need to know that and so in fact
that's a problem because if your tensor
is really developed you could be sitting
in Hip medial rotation when you
shouldn't be
and if your glutes are really good
that'll also immediately rotate your hip
when you're sitting that's a problem
okay
yeah okay so one of the ways to if
you're trying to do the quadruped thing
is to turn your hip out a little bit
when you're in the quadruped position so
your feet would come together a little
bit closer right more of like a
wrestling partier position yeah I don't
know I never wrestled oh yeah yeah I
could I can pick up the slack on on
explaining that then so not with a
referee anyway
okay anyway right right so from the feet
to the knees it would just be making a
very very very slight v-shape it's not a
v-shape but the the lines would converge
in other words your feet would be a
little bit closer together exactly
you're funny
all right so that makes a lot of sense
to me and I'm certainly comfortable with
that what what would it mean or how
would you read the movement pattern that
I have of sitting and having my legs
sort of splay open that's also something
really good that alleviates my low back
symptoms if I'm staying in a chair
oftentimes I'll take my shoes off and
fold them up on top of the chair
restaurants hate this by the way
so I do get chastised occasionally but
but it alleviates some of my lower back
issues yeah you're getting it four and
aft because
you're probably in this this is one of
the syndromes I have of the hip that
I've described to the hip because if
your tensors really develop it's going
to be holding your femur in medial
rotation when you're standing because
it's pulled taut then if your gluteals
are really well developed
when your hips flexed to 90 degrees they
become medial rotators too so they're
trying to hold your hip and medial
rotation and you're probably getting
that Twist on your back then do you see
what I mean yeah so when you laterally
rotate your hips
then you're taking that pull off of them
taking the pressure off of it yeah yeah
you're not getting that extra pull on
your pelvis from those gluteal muscles
being pulled so taut and that's where
you should be that's your your normal
thing because you have femoral
retroversion
see that's one of the things that's bad
is because you know like when people go
in and they're not dead lifts and they
say well make your feet Point Straight
Ahead well
many men in particular shouldn't have
their feet pointing straight ahead
because they have this femoral
retroversion
and also when they do things that rotate
like play golf their feet should be
turned out because if they're Straight
Ahead they're in at the end of their
medial rotation range yeah do you see
what I mean or the back or the hips that
are going to go
hmm
makes a lot of sense yeah it's also
interesting
yeah super fascinating yeah it's like
the backbones attached to the pelvic
bone you know and I think to me that's
what's so valuable about
being a physical therapist or looking at
people because I can't like an
orthopedic surgeon just look at the knee
or I can't just look at the hip because
it's the result of all of these
interactions of the body that's what's
so important